let's go to our next caller from the 732
area code 732 historically has been a
tough area code for us so we'll see who
this is it can be it can be great or not
so great who's there from 7 3 2 hey
David this is Danny from I'm actually in
San Diego California but my area codes
from New Jersey
Oh all right then I'm sure you won't be
a problem today well I'm actually from
New Jersey but I am along with your
ideas on basically everything well maybe
I doing I guess we'll see so my question
for you is about universal health care
ok I like the way Bernie Sanders and
roll Khanna kind of used a Republican
point of view when they went after B's
O's with the stop ethos Act you know
with taxing them on the welfare money
I'm using a conservative standpoint to
say hey how can you guys be against this
these are traditional conservative
values we don't want to pay you know you
guys don't want to pay welfare money you
know we're trying to do something to fix
that so the way I pull that back to
universal health care is you know I'm a
small business owner and universal
health care and health care is one of my
biggest expenses you know if it wasn't
for that I'd be able to hire more people
pay people more etc etc wouldn't that be
a good way to kind of present universal
health care so it's one way even Bernie
Sanders I don't hear him present it to
too much in that way that this will help
small business this will help small
businesses grow because health care is
one of the biggest burdens expense wise
for small businesses you know I have
heard him present that I mean in the
plan that the the the version of the
plan that outlined that there would be a
payroll tax for employers and that also
there would be a surplus tax for people
in order to pay for single-payer health
for Medicare for all but both of those
costs would be less than what the
employer and employees currently pay for
a combination of premiums and co-pays
and coinsurance and all of that other
stuff so I mean I I have seen that case
made I think it's a really great case to
make
I don't know that Republicans are going
to be swayed by it but I have
I have heard it be made yeah I don't
think that the politicians will be
swayed by it because you know they just
don't they just don't believe what they
say anyway but yeah maybe the Republican
voters would be more so swayed by it
especially the ones that are small
business owners because it is an
excellent point
I have seen him bring it up but I see it
brought up a whole lot less than the
other points related to universal health
care yeah I mean I think the way I hear
it brought up all the time is there will
be some taxes to pay for this but it
will be a net reduction in cost to both
employers and end-users how many
employees do you have that you have to
provide health care eight and I didn't
think that would eight you had to
provide health care no we don't but you
know this is the right thing to do okay
and it would be less it would it would
be a less of a burden if we you know
didn't have to sure yeah but you are I
mean you you want to provide it and you
are doing the right thing which I think
says a lot about you know not every
business is doing what you're doing no
yeah absolutely I wouldn't have it any
other way but yeah it would be
definitely helpful if the government
just kind of stepped in and took care of
that especially because it would
probably be better quality overall for
everybody including myself as the
business owner agreed agreed 100% well
thank you thank you for doing that and
thanks for the call I appreciate it
thank you David all right